il s'agit pas pour moi de me substituer
à l'expertisé des personnes qui
travaillent dans le domaine de la santé
ou de dire que les recommandations que
jeu qui me sont inspirés par ce que j'ai
entendu ce soir sont plus pertinente que
celle du gouvernement
mais moi ce qui m'a interpellé c'est
vraiment à la fois les témoignages et
tout ce que j'ai entendu qui est de
l'ordre de l'impact sur la santé mentale
l'impression que j'ai dans l'option de
confinement qu'on a choisi aujourd'hui
et y compris dans les mots qui ont été
ceux du président de la république dans
son intervention du mois d'octobre quand
il a parlé de contacts utiles et de
contacts festif c'est que les seuls
contacts qui valent le coup en fait
d'être nourris en ce moment sont donc
des contacts qui sont potentiellement
productif
or karim l'a très bien dit le lien
social existe aussi à travers les
commerces qu'on peut avoir au jour le
jour à travers les interactions qu'on a
quand on travaille quand on rencontre
ses collègues et je pense que le
confinement va avoir un impact
extrêmement important sur la santé
mentale des français un impact qui
durera bien au delà de la fin de la
période qu'on est en train de vivre on
est dans une période qu'on appelle la
dépression saisonnière ou en fait du
fait de l'absence de luminosité beaucoup
de gens en fait on une baisse de moral
voire des pensées suicidaires a ajouté
cela au confinement qui implique le fait
qu'on soit moins souvent à l'extérieur
donc plus chez soi et qu'on voit moins
de personnes qui sont susceptibles en
fait de nous rassurer par rapport à
l'autre estime personnelle est tout
simplement nourrir ce qui caractérise
quand même les sociétés humaines c'est
si le fait de voir des champions et pas
de voir les gens uniquement dans le but
que cette relation produisent de
l'argent donc moi en fait ce qui
m'intéresse ce n'est pas tant l'état du
confinement mais c'est l'option comprend
et sur quoi on met l'accent aujourd'hui
j'étais l'avenir l'impression que c'est
que on est on est aujourd'hui des êtres
la mission adjoint français oui et on
n'est pas seulement des êtres qui sont
voués à travailler notre vie sont pas
ces gens travaillent pas l'option qu'ont
appris ce pardon de le dire de peindre
donnez moi je faisais ma question est ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est que
j'espère que qu'effectivement c'est
quelque chose qui a été pensé mais mais
mais que que que le ben du coup j'ai
perdu un peu l'idée que j'avais mais
bien une étude qui a été faite par les
petits frères des pauvres qui dit que
sur 41 % des personnes âgées
le confinement un impact négatif sur
leur santé mentale et de dire que en
fait j'ai l'impression qu'on promeut
dans ce qui est fait ce qui nous
caractérise entendant temps 80 notre
capacité à travailler plus que le fait
qu' on vit ensemble et ça ça fait partie
de la santé c'est à dire que la santé
mentale
ça fait partie de la santé et que dans
un contexte d'urgence sanitaire on peut
pas dire que l'urgence est uniquement
d'être en bonne santé physique
si la santé mentale n'est pas prise en
charge de la même manière moi ce que je
veux savoir c'est qu'est-ce que vous
avez mis en place pour vous assurer que
les français ne soient pas dans une
forme de dépression qui nous impacte en
fait pendant des années parce que ça a
aussi un impact sur l'économie sur les
places dans précisément libéral ce qu'on
a mis en place d'abord c'est qu'on n'a
pas mis mes mêmes règles du confinement
pourquoi on envoie les enfants à l'école
parce que ça circule moins bien mais
aussi parce qu'il ya des contacts au
delà de la transmission au delà de
l'éducation au delà du fait et ça c'est
pas une activité productive au sens
propre du terme s'agit pas d'aller
bosser
il s'agit de faire en sorte que ces
gamins ils puissent courir dans la cour
ils puissent voir leurs copains
moi j'ai trois enfants donc j'ai vu en
direct live que c'est le confinement sur
trois enfants 9 ans 14 à 18 ans j'ai la
chance que 18 ans a tenu la boutique
mais c'est je dire on a fait ce choix
aussi pour que ces gamins passent ce cap
au delà du fait qu'il ya des inégalités
en matière d'accès à l'éducation et je
pense pas que vous dirais le contraire
qui sont massives et qu'on pouvait pas
accepter de les développer et de les
accroître par le confinement est
effective mais les promesses jerry choix
osé parce que mes miracle ce virus
semble être moins prégnant sur les
enfants vous imaginez si ça n'avait pas
été le cas si ça n'avait pas été qu'un
la deuxième chose les personnes âgées
on a alors qu'au premier continent on
est allé très stricte sur les épate très
stricte sur les visites des personnes
âgées
on s'est dit ce n'était pas tenable on a
appris du premier confinement en a dit
qu'il fallait maintenir des visites chez
les personnes âgées terme en ehpad la
première sur la première vague madame et
tous les médecins ça a été l'erreur on
peut revenir sur les masques les tests
mais d'avoir empêché d'avoir casser le
lien affectif des personnes âgées
on l'a vécue alors qu'il suffisait de
tester une personne par famille une
seule personne qui allait voir
ça a été un drame ça a été terrible et
les enterrements madame à l'as pitié
salpêtrière y avait un camion mettez les
corps on avait loué le d
un autre fois registre pour m c'était
terrible parce que le deuil ne peut se
faire que si l' enterrement fia une
cérémonie
et vous imaginez au delà de tous les
imaginer mes sujets aussi par rapport
aux cultes rapport au culte parce que
moi j'ai un ami qui à la tête du centre
hospitalier de seine-saint-denis donc il
a plusieurs types de culte le musulman
le juif etc et le déchirement des
familles où vous aviez la personne dans
la housse mortuaire fermé mais c'est ce
que vous dites et qui avaient au plus
haut on savait qu'il y avait aucune
transmission le lac ont vite par chance
à ses rivaux la danse à céret de l'école
je suis vous et c'est pour ça qu'on a
bouger les curseurs c'est pour ça qu'on
s'est dit c'est pas tenable les
personnes âgées elles doivent être elle
doit voir des leurs proches
régulièrement donc non on a fait bouger
secure ça et je suis complètement
d'accord avec vous l'aspect
psychologique dans ce confinement il est
essentiel on le voit dans le télétravail
moi j'ai des salariés qu'ils nous disent
moi je ne tiens pas je tiens pas cinq
jours sur cinq en télétravail
alors tu choisis quoi la dépression ou
le confinement